like who who's one journalist that we
can point at and say wow that's the guy
back in the day was walter cronkite who
is today i don't know maybe he's a joe
rogerson um maybe it's joe rogan glenn
greenwood that's how
he's what do you think my bread bear
uh great bench press
that's it
i like brett bear i like bread bear i
don't know i don't know that uh i'm a
huge fan of burrito we know that and
i'll say one thing about fried zakari
he's on cnn so everyone you know in the
chatterbox he's amazing journalist he's
indian-born american-made i'm sure you
can respect that he did something the
other day on his show that i was like
whoa
he did a show and he goes hey my last
point i actually said something last
week that was wrong
and i'm here to correct it today and
this was the point it wasn't even a
major point but he came out and i was
like oh okay thanks yeah but i think
more journalists need to do that brian
stelter no
do you know what you know a big problem
is that the word uh
when when people think
so journalists and pundits are different
things yep but they they've been
merged again you know don lemon is a
pundit tucker carlson is a pundit right
uh sean hannity
yeah they're they're pundits rachel
maddow are pundits
but
they're conflated with journalists yeah
right to me a journalist is someone who
who
gives the news like reads the news and
it's actually a fairly unbiased yeah as
long as what they're reading is
objective
there's not much room to you know they
don't even really get space to give
their opinion maybe they could do it in
their tone or whatever so but i think
that when people think journalists we go
to these famous faces who really are
pundits
more yeah they're sort of journalists to
a degree well none of those guys would
have matched those scores by the way
every now and then
but they're not trying to but why can't
they put on the bottom of the screen
this is an opinion well they this
they don't present it as news they
present it as editorial so what do you
mean presented it doesn't say that on
the tv
turn on your tv and it's boom the news
guys lady all right i'm watching the
news espn came out a year and a half ago
and says that we're no longer committed
to sports we're committed to
editorializing sports steven
they they're not biggest editorials
opinions they don't they don't play
highlights anymore it's there's nothing
light there's no i haven't i haven't
watched mtv or espn in it's got to be
i've watched honestly and this is all i
ever watched growing up was mtv espn mtv
especially just go back and forth
between those two things hours and hours
and hours every day i'd go from singled
out to sportscenter to uh uh whatever
trl trl live to to uh you know then you
know outside the lines with you know
like i would just go back and forth
those two channels that was it i i've
watched maybe 15 minutes total of the
two channels in the last two three years
and it's because they're no longer
commit they are the story and their
narrative is first it's no longer about
watching the home runs or the dunks it's
about well what does this dunk mean for
society and it's like i don't care yeah
i don't care what you have to say i
don't this is uh i think it's worth
saying this is this problem exists in
the uk but it's worse in the us
it's really really polarized here like
the the media it's very much have you
fully recognized that since being here
for the last month or so i mean i've
seen it for you many years you know um i
mean i remember you know as a kid
growing up in saudi i mean we did get
cnn out there and fox news etc and i
remember growing up everyone always knew
that fox news was like right leaning but
cnn was certainly deemed supposed to be
the center yeah yeah and it did it did
used to be sent to the new york times
yeah it was the paper of record yeah it
did used to be much more so whereas now
especially i i haven't i haven't owned a
tv for 12 years so when i do watch the
news it really strikes me how
propagandistic it is right so i turn it
on and i'm just like whoa like this is
just straight down this side especially
when trump was in office oh my gosh it
was literally like straight down this
way straight what was his famous line
about the media the media the enemy of
the man
you think the media took that well that
was a bar
who cares was he wrong he was right he
was right i mean the way they're
dividing people in the past year and a
half depends on what team past year and
a half you know half the population
thinks that you know there's like a mild
flu slash cold that's going around the
world which is like you know like very
minimal other people think that
we're we're in the middle of a
black plague armageddon and you know a
state like florida oh my gosh you know
what are they calling your governor
death scientists like oh my gosh florida
is like they're going to kill all the
people what if i mean i'm here i'm like
those are all the good people by the way
we're the bad people those are the but
people are really living in people are
living in absolutely different realities
and that creates and that was created by
the media all around the world right
intentionally yeah intentionally which
is where when i'm like man the immediate
is the enemy of the people especially
when people are now fighting each other
and you know literally people are
advocating for segregation now well
that's my question in the uk
are the politics i identity politics as
well there are there their political
divisions based on your immutable
characteristics they've imported it
somewhat from the u.s
so the uk has a bad habit of taking the
us's worst the worst aspects of the us
like i love the usa one of my favorite
countries in the world but there are a
couple things here which i think are
really really toxic sociopolitically and
culturally and one of those things is
identity politics in its various forms
like in the us people are too obsessed
with race
way too obsessed with race i understand
it somewhat from the history i mean you
guys use the terms asian american black
american african-american why am i
in england we say british
british like if someone said i'm black
british or afro african british they'd
be like why why'd you say that like why
using that term right but here like race
is like big on labeling yeah the
labeling it runs through everything it
runs through the meat and people don't
realize it because it's like the default
here right but when you're looking at it
as an outsider i'm like why why are you
that why is there always so in the white
black and the next i don't think it
always was the default i think it points
specifically to carter and affirmative
action because i don't know
be your
when carter did affirmative action this
is just before pat came here right so
it became beneficial to label yourself
they became there there became an actual
profit incentive i mean i think it'd be
labeled i think it goes way back it goes
way before that i mean the us has a
specific history in regards to race
right and so these designations
black et cetera yeah but you but you but
uk didn't have like you know slavery etc
and segregation the way jim crow all
that you you didn't have all that and
also the us is much more racially and
ethnically diverse
and so i understand where it comes from
it's just that i'm like yo it's 20 21
like why are people still really locked
into that
i don't think it's going to go away it's
a formula to divide and it's working
very effectively but you know even
you're talking about cnn earlier
somebody commented about ted turner if
you've ever read ted turner's book call
me ted i don't know if you guys have
read it or not the ending of the book is
fascinating
where he's interviewing one of the
current uh folks at cnn and he says i'm
so disappointed what you guys have done
to cnn this is not why i started cnn ted
turner ted turner said that since i
didn't start cnn to be like this
when did he say that this this is a book
he wrote years ago this is not a recent
book call me to i highly recommend
everybody go by his book call me ted it
is fascinating what this man did with
his life
and how he went from who he was to who
he married to the personal life do you
know alcohol he talks openly about
everything there is nothing he holds
back he tells himself i'm a great father
i'm a terrible husband like the stuff he
goes through with the book it's a book
you won't be able to put down but at the
end he calls out cnn he says i am so
disappointed
with what cnn turned into at the end of
the book highly recommend people seeing
it so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]